[Music]  all y'all rappers out there  think y'all hard cause what y'all been  through hey y'all  check it out it was friday night chillin  on my front lawn  me and my crew i had my bathrobe on  everybody high just watched x-men  got plenty chicken heads ready for sex  man  musters roll up they trying to talk  smack  don't these  [Music]  still  [Music]  went back to my palace fast  now i'm the dude walking around with a  phallus cast  like wolverine i'm trying to be a loner  but they think i  got an adamantium boner what can i say  they still up on my totem pole [ __ ] get  your tongue ring away from the scrotum  hole  don't know why they love it but it keeps  the ladies moistening  gave half the honeys in the hood lead  poisoning  shot shot shot  [Music]  still standing  [Music]  damn that hurts damn no  video over man video's over i'm serious  man  damn  you